everyone welcome back and let's write
some more neat code today so today let's
look at a graph problem actually it's
called
course schedule we're given a total
number of courses and these are our
nodes and they're labeled from zero
to n minus 1 basically so some courses
have
prerequisites for example if you want to
take course 0
you have to first take course 1 and
that's represented as a pair
or as an edge in our graph so if you
want to take course
zero you have to first take course one
and the only
question we want to answer is is it
possible for us to finish every course
so let's just look at the first example
where given number of courses are two so
that means we have one course
zero and another course one we know that
the prerequisites are like
this meaning that if we want to take
course one
we have to first take course 0 and i'm
going to represent it as an
edge going outward from 1
into 0. so what do they mean by possible
let's just run through each of our
courses and see is it possible to take
each one
so for zero is it possible to take zero
well we don't have any
outward edges from zero so that means
zero does not have any prerequisites so
it is possible for us to complete course
zero then we look at course one it has
one prerequisite which is
zero and we know zero is possible to
complete
so once we finish course zero then we're
allowed to take
course one which has no other
prerequisites right the only
prerequisite was
course zero so therefore both of these
courses are possible
to complete so we can return true
so let's look at an example where it's
actually impossible so we're given
n equals two that means we have two
courses
zero and one and we're given two
prerequisites so
one zero and zero one this one means
that if we want to finish course one we
have to first complete
course zero so zero is a prerequisite
the second one means that if we want to
finish course
zero we have to finish course one first
so
one is a prerequisite of zero so the
problem with this
is kind of obvious right there's a cycle
so we if we want to finish course zero
we gotta go finish course one
if we wanna finish course one we gotta
finish course zero and it just goes like
that
forever so neither of the courses are
possible to finish
so in this case we return false
so we can actually solve this problem
using
depth first search we can also use
breadth first search and i'm going to
show you
just the depth for search version
because i like it better
so given this new example the first
thing you want to do is visualize it so
i'm going to draw a picture
so we're given five nodes so we have
zero one
two three four that's five nodes
we're also given five prerequisites so
in this case we end up having five
edges right from zero to one zero to two
one two three one to four
and three to four so my goal here
is for each of these nodes i just want
to know right for each of these
classes can we complete this course or
not
and how do we know if a course can be
completed well
just looking at this picture is obvious
right xero has a prerequisite
of two but two does not have any
prerequisites which is great
it also has a prerequisite of one and
one has
two prerequisites three and four
three has one prerequisite of four and
four
luckily for us does not have any
prerequisites
so looking at this it's kind of obvious
that
we can complete all these courses so
let's do the algorithm to be able to
determine that
we see that these are kind of our base
cases right 2
and 4 don't have any prerequisites
that's useful information but we don't
need a graph to tell us that
we can use a data structure called an
adjacency list
and i'm going to call it prerequisite
map because the
what the data structure i'm going to use
is a hashmap to represent this
so for each of our courses we are going
to have
a list of all of its prerequisites so
for zero we know
zero has two prerequisites one and two
and we're going to repeat that for every
single course so for one
we know that two does not have any
prerequisites so we can just put
an empty list over here 4 also does not
have any prerequisites so we get another
empty list so now we're going to run
depth first search on
every single node i'm going to do it in
the order from
zero to n minus one so
be starting at zero so we're going to
run debt first search on it right
how are we gonna do the depth first
search well we have our prerequisite map
so we're gonna do it recursively we see
that it has two prerequisites
one and two so now let's run depth first
search
on the first neighbor
one so now we look at one we see that it
has two neighbors
three and four so let's recursively run
depth first search
on its first neighbor three so since
three is a prerequisite of one
now we wanna know if we can take we can
complete course three
so we look at its prerequisites it only
has
one four so now we're going to check
it's only prerequisite
for can we complete course four and then
we want to look at the prerequisites
of course for which we know are empty
this is good right so now we see that
this is empty
so what does that tell us that tells us
course 4
can be completed which we basically
already
knew because course 4 has an empty
uh empty prerequisite list so i'm just
going to put a little
check mark here to say that we know
course 4
can be completed and so recursively
we're going to
end up going back to our three and we
see that it only had
one prerequisite and we were able to
complete that prerequisite for
so therefore three is also
a course that can be completed and so
what we can actually do
is from its prerequisite list we see
four we can just remove the four we
know it can be completed and so i'm
representing that
by having an empty list here right just
an empty list means that it has no
prerequisites therefore it can be
completed so i removed the only
prerequisite that three
had then from three we can actually go
backwards to one which we see here
we can kind of get rid of this 3 because
we know
3 can be completed and then from the 3
we're going to end up going to 4 to
check again
if 4 can be completed because it is a
prerequisite
of one and since we already know four
can be completed we can get rid of that
as well so now we know for sure that one
can also be completed and now
i'm gonna go back to zero which is where
we how we even got to one in the first
place and we look at the prerequisites
of zero
we see one is no longer a prerequisite
because we
basically know that one can be completed
but we still have to look at this
too so then we're gonna go to the last
unvisited node in our entire graph which
is
two so now we've gotten to the last
course two we see it's an empty list
right
therefore two can be completed it has
no neighbors it has no prerequisites so
i can put a little check mark here
two can be completed and then we can
finally go
back to our original node 0
cross out its last prerequisite which
was
2 and now when we look at 0 even
0 has an empty list of prerequisites
therefore we know zero can be completed
so since we were able to complete every
single
course that that means we can return
true
every course is completable and the time
complexity for this
is going to be big o the
number of nodes we have which is n i'll
use
n as that and i'll use p for the number
of prerequisites that we had
because if you notice in this graph we
have to
we have to visit every single node
and we have to visit and we have to move
along
every single edge and once we get rid
of the prerequisites from here we don't
really have to
visit a course twice because once we
know it can be completed
we we can instantly do that we don't
have to go through its prerequisites
twice
so i'm gonna show you one last example
this is the example
that what we're going to do how are we
actually going to detect this loop
because we see
so i'm just going to cross this stuff
out because we're looking at a different
example
but here we see that zero has a
prerequisite of one
one has a preset pre-rec of two two has
a pre-rec of 3. so this is a loop
we cannot complete these courses but how
can we actually
how can we actually detect this loop i'm
going to show you how really quickly so
to detect a loop i'm going to use one
last data structure and it's going to be
a
set though i think you could just use an
array if you want to call it the visit
set and all it's going to contain is the
list
of courses that we're currently visiting
along
our depth first search so let's say we
start at 0 then we add zero
to our visit set we take a look at the
prerequisites of zero we see it as one
prerequisite so then we
move to one so now we visit one
so we're going to add one to our visit
set and we look at the prerequisites of
one it has one prerequisite two so then
we
move to two we run debt for search on
two
so to do that we have to first visit two
so
two is also going to be added to our
visit set and lastly
we see two has one prerequisite of zero
so then we of course want to
visit zero and so now we're going to
visit
zero twice but you see that zero is
already in the visit set therefore we
detected
a loop therefore we have to return
false these courses cannot be
completed so now let's finally look at
the code so
the first thing i want to do is create
our pre-map
so our list of prerequisites so we know
for each
course initially we can set it to an
empty list so an empty list of
prerequisites and we want to do that for
every course that we got which the
number of that is just
number of courses so this is if you're
not familiar this is some python stuff
i'm just saying that for every course
initially we want to map it to an
empty list and we know that the
prerequisites are actually contained in
this
nested list variable so let's iterate
through that let's get each
course prerequisite pair from that list
and then just start appending them so
pre-map
of course we want to append to this list
this prerequisite so we also want a
visit
set which is going to store
the it's going to store all the courses
along the current depth first search
path and of course it's initially just
going to be empty so since we're going
to do this
recursively i'm going to define a nested
function depth first search inside of
our can finish function because then
we'll have access
to all these variables without having to
pass them in as a parameter
the only parameter that we have to pass
in is the current
course that we're visiting and so like
most recursive functions we want to look
at our base cases first the first
base case is if course is in
the visit set already so what this
means is that we're visiting a course
twice
so we detected a loop so we can return
false meaning that this course cannot be
completed
the other base case we know is if
the prerequisites of this course happen
to be an
empty list what that tells us is that
this course
has no prerequisites and we can return
true because it can definitely
be completed if neither of these
conditions that
is satisfied then we can take this
course
and add it to our visit set because that
means we are currently visiting this and
we're going to recursively run debt
first search
on its prerequisites so i'm gonna loop
through the prerequisites of this course
for each one i'm gonna run debt for
search on it
so debt first search on this
prerequisite if it happens to return
false though then we know we can return
false immediately we don't have to wait
because if we find
one course that can't be completed then
we can return false for the entire
function
so i forgot to put a not over here so if
not meaning if
it returns false then we return false
but if this does not execute that means
it's a course that can be taken and
we want to return true in that case but
before we return true we want to remove
it from our visit set
because we are no longer visiting this
we've already finished visiting it
so visit remove this course
and also since we know this course can
be visited
what we can do is say pre-map we can
set it to an empty list so that
if if we ever have to run debt first
search on it again
we will in that case execute this
condition
and return true immediately we will not
have to repeat
all this work of running debt first
search on
its neighbors so that's all for our debt
for search function
the function is done all we have to do
is call it now
but we have to potentially call it for
every single
course in the number of courses that we
have
and if any of them happen to return
false
then we have to return false immediately
and if they don't return false then we
can return
true all courses can be completed
and the reason we are looping like this
is mainly because
what if our graph is not fully connected
like what if we have a graph like this
one has a prerequisite of two
and maybe three has a prerequisite
of four so these are two separate
graphs that are not connected right so
we have to ch we have to
manually iterate through every course
and check
can one be completed can two be
completed can three
and can four be completed so this is the
depth first search
solution you can see that it does run
very efficiently about as efficiently as
the breadth for search solution as well
and i hope this was helpful if it was
please like and subscribe it supports
the channel a lot and i'll hopefully
see you pretty soon